SCP-682.
Does it even require an introduction?
The SCP Foundation thinks this cantankerous
reptile needs a serious attitude adjustment
- By which we mean, they really, really want
to kill it.
But as you might have seen in our previous
videos on the subject, they don’t call this
monstrosity the “Hard to Destroy Reptile”
for nothing.
That’s why we’ve done what the Foundation
isn’t allowed to - we outsourced the dirty
job of squashing this lizard to all of you!
We made a community post asking for your ideas
on how this scaly abomination can finally
be destroyed, and you delivered big time!
A truly staggering amount with over 6,000
comments!
Now let’s see if we can finally get our
answer, because believe us, the Foundation
is desperate at this point.
Idk what to write for a name said, “The
most effective way that Dr Bright approves
of: CHAINSAW CANNON.”
As awesome as a chainsaw cannon would probably
be to use, it sadly wouldn’t be very effective
against SCP-682.
Chainsaws are blades, and we know from the
termination test logs that blades have been
ineffective.
Even when SCP-682 is chopped up into tiny
little pieces, those pieces have a nasty habit
of reforming into the big, ugly monster we
all know and fear.
AwesomeCardinal said, “The SCP Foundation
could try to bring it to the void in Russia
where the Pattern Screamers are.”
This was a popular idea and the Foundation
actually tried this.
The SCP being referred to here is SCP-3930,
a big ol’ pile of nothing in Russia that
causes things inside it to stop existing.
When they threw SCP-682 inside, it technically
did stop existing.
Despite this, it could still be perceived,
and still caused the deaths of all surrounding
researchers.
Fifteen hours later, it just reappeared in
its containment chamber, apparently totally
fine.
You can probably see why the Foundation is
frustrated by this thing.
Sc0r3cr0w and Friends said, “Black hole.
Need I say more?”
You may need to say a little more.
For starters, there would be logistical issues
in actually getting the creature anywhere
near a black hole.
But there’s also the concern that it may
just adapt its body to respond to the intense
gravity present near a black hole.
Or, even scarier, somehow adapts to reproduce
the powers of a black hole.
It probably wouldn’t be worth the risk of
ending up with a reptile capable of creating
gamma ray bursts.
StellarSolar Sky said, “Put the reptile
inside nuclear fusion and watch its particles
disappear.”
The Foundation tried something pretty close
to this, by trying to put it inside SCP-536
- A chamber where they can use dials to control
the physical constants within.
They increased the speed of light and nuclear
force within the chamber, which caused SCP-682
to disintegrate until all that was left was
a piece of matter 1% of its original size.
However, the creature then reformed and killed
the researchers.
Later tests showed that its body had become
an unknown form of matter, held together by
quantum effects impossible to unravel with
our current understanding of science.
Bray of fun said, “So you know that coffee
machine thing that is 294?
Type in "682 killing substance" and repeat
that until you have enough to fill its entire
room, then fill it.”
They did actually try this, and the resulting
substance was effective in damaging SCP-682’s
tissue.
However, the one problem is that it’s extremely
difficult to produce enough of this stuff
to actually submerge the creature.
Worse still, if enough of it was made to cause
significant damage to the body of SCP-682,
it may adapt to the chemical as a defense
mechanism, making it ineffective as a weapon.
Its adaptive ability is truly SCP-682’s
greatest asset when it comes to thwarting
the Foundation’s constant attempts to kill
it.
Alex Webb said, “Ask it kindly to die.”
We don’t believe that the Foundation has
ever actually tried this one, but just based
on the fact that SCP-682 is a huge jerk on
top of being an omnicidal monster, he probably
wouldn’t respond to polite requests.
iFlashboy said, “I wonder if Doom Slayer
could defeat the reptile.
He’s torn through every demon in hell, and
even titans, so would 682 be a challenge or
just another Tuesday for the slayer?”
That’s a slightly trickier one.
Of course, since they exist in different universes,
we’ll never see an official battle between
the Doom Slayer and SCP-682.
However, given that the Doom Slayer’s weapons
are all conventional - meaning, largely based
around slashing, crushing, shooting, and blasting
- we don’t know whether he’d actually
be able to slay the beast.
That being said, we don’t know if 682 could
kill him, either.
We could have a stalemate on our hands here...
Amanda Breneman said, “I asked my sister
(who’s never heard of SCP’s) this question,
and her answer was “You hit it again”.”
Amanda, your sister may be the one to finally
stop this creature.
Getting the two of them in the same room may
be the biggest logistical problem here.
Samuel Pascual said, “Throwing him down
SCP-087, so he suffers and is contained once
and for all in the improbable case he is still
alive.”
SCP-087 - the Endless Staircase - can be a
dangerous anomaly for humans who don’t know
what they’re getting into.
However, SCP-682 would likely detect the threat
far earlier than any human, and then breach
containment.
It’s definitely gotten out of stickier situations.
Yashasheree Charya said, “Send him to endless
IKEA where he will be trapped forever.”
Much like SCP-087, the Endless Ikea wouldn’t
pose the same threat to SCP-682 as it would
for the average human trapped inside.
The staff would be no trouble for 682, and
it would be able to devote pretty much all
of its time in there to finding a way out.
And when he did finally break out, he’d
probably be armed with the terrifying knowledge
of how to correctly assemble a svendendorkk.
We shudder at the thought.
Jack Lost said, “Oxygen Destroyer.
Used to deal with another big lizard issue
back in 1954.”
Sadly, this would also likely be an ineffective
weapon against SCP-682, because the creature
thrives in anaerobic environments - seeing
as its native atmosphere seems to have no
oxygen, and according to Foundation tests,
it can survive just fine in a vacuum.
Whether SCP-682 could take Godzilla in a fight
is still up for debate and you can argue about
which lizard would reign supreme in the comments.
Ace Godwin said, “Just don’t kill him,
let him live, bro, he hasn't done anything
wrong yet.
Let him vibe in his chamber.”
Wait a second…
Did SCP-682 write this?
Moving on.
A lot of you said, “Throw him into the sun.”
While the sun is a gigantic nuclear furnace
where hydrogen is built into helium at a temperature
of millions of degrees, there is the the issue
of it not only being beyond difficult to incapacitate
the creature for long enough to get it into
the rocket, but also the problem of the sun
being 93 millions miles away from earth.
It’s a long trip there no matter what, and
during that time, SCP-682 would almost definitely
figure out a way to return to earth.
It might even rewire the rocket and turn it
into its own personal vehicle, giving it the
freedom to cause chaos around the solar system.
And even if everything else went well, SCP-682
would still probably survive being thrown
into the sun.
After all, The Gate Guardian’s flaming sword
is described as being hotter than the sun,
and it didn’t manage to kill the hard-to-destroy
reptile.
PokemonRedBoy said, “Send him to Mars and
launch a nuke that can destroy a planet along
with the SCP.”
While a nuke capable of destroying the planet
Mars would also likely destroy SCP-682 in
the process, the destruction of Mars itself
would likely cause such a catastrophic shift
in our neck of the solar system that we’d
probably die with it.
The question, at that point, is whether it’s
really worth killing ourselves to take down
the lizard?
Artemis said, “Let it live with 999 its
entire life and it's not a threat.”
This is a double-edged sword.
During their cross-test, SCP-999 did pacify
SCP-682 and put it in a state of bliss and
laughter for a brief period.
However, this actually resulted in a pretty
catastrophic tragedy, too.
682 adapted to 999’s effects and released
a beam of laughter that incapacitated everyone
around it, allowing it to escape and go on
a killing spree.
So maybe the two are better kept apart...
Dr. wasup said, “I'd give 682 a jar of pickles
to open, and the jar would be so tight that
682 couldn't open it and he would be so embarrassed
by it that he would just destroy himself.”
You may actually be on to something here.
We know we’d be extremely embarrassed if
we couldn’t open the jar.
But there are three major problems.
One, where does one get such a jar?
Can SCP-343 make a jar of pickles so difficult
to open that even he himself can’t open
it?
Two, we don’t know if SCP-682 likes pickles
enough to make opening the jar an attractive
prospect.
And three, if it does turn out it likes pickles,
it would probably just eat the jar too.
Shuvro Bhattacharjee said, “To deal with
him in my opinion, send SCP-682 into SCP-3001,
aka the Red Reality.
That's my theory.”
This could potentially be an effective method
of trapping SCP-682 for a period of time.
However, the problem is that there’s no
reliable way to access the Red Reality.
The only person who’s ever really been inside
is Robert Scranton, and he ended up there
completely by accident.
So this doesn’t seem to be a reliable neutralization
method for SCP-682.
Adding to that, the panel that Dr. Scranton
was transported to the Red Reality with eventually
came back, which means it might only be a
temporary solution anyway.
MistakeToSociaty Yay said, “Can someone
ride SCP-682 without them dying?”
This isn’t technically about neutralizing
SCP-682, but it deserves an answer.
While it appears that some people are able
to ride 682 such as SCP-053, the Little Girl
and 05-6 aka The American in the Ouroboros
cycle, he doesn’t seem to enjoy it.
At least he didn’t when SCP-082, better
known as Fernand the Cannibal attempted it.
Of course Fernand describes their relationship
quite differently, insisting that 682 is his
Bayard… his magical steed.
Laura Garcia said, “Chop it up, put the
pieces in a giant bowl with egg beaters stirring
it constantly so it can't reanimate.
Keep it kinetically moving so it doesn't ever
have the rest time to reform.
Giant Egg Beating Machine to prevent Reformation.
Killing it would take a Rigel sun blast to
stop it from reanimating itself.”
This has got to be one of the most creative
ones we’ve encountered.
Even Dr. Bright probably wouldn’t think
to use giant whisks on the beast.
However, it probably wouldn’t kill the ornery
creature for good.
As we’ve said before, not only has the beast
regenerated from things as hot as the sun,
he’s also able to remanifest from the tiniest
atoms, or even nothing at all.
On the plus side, he may reanimate with a
new super whisking ability, and could potentially
give SCP-5031 a run for best cook in containment.
Shaked ben yakar said, “I think they need
to explode him from the inside because maybe
there's one spot in his body that isn't invincible
and if they hurt it SCP-682 will die.”
The problem with SCP-682 isn’t necessarily
that it’s invincible, just hyper-adaptive
and hyper-regenerative.
As you may have seen in other videos, SCP-682
has been shot, dismembered, burned, frozen,
vaporized, blown up, partially eaten, and
even totally disintegrated.
But it always manages to come back, even from
the smallest specs of matter.
It would almost admirable… if it wasn’t
a perpetually-aggressive murder monster.
Brybot said, “Put it in 106's pocket dimension.”
This actually happened once during a containment
breach where the Old Man as well as SCP-953
the Polymorphic Humanoid ended up in 682’s
cell.
SCP-106 dragged them all into its pocket dimension
for a bit of the old ultra-violence, and when
they emerged, it was clear that they’d all
taken considerable damage.
SCP-682 wasn’t killed though, and 106 hasn’t
tried anything like that again since.
NonPlayerCactus said, “Trick him into killing
John Wick's dog.”
To be fair, if anyone could take this monster
down, it’d probably be John Wick.
Though SCP-682 might be too smart to actually
kill his dog in the first place.
And if he did manage to best John Wick?
Well we hate to think what a 682 with the
martial prowess and gun skills of John Wick
would be like.
Actually no, we don’t hate to think about
it, because it would be awesome.
These are just a little taster plate of the
huge and varied potential murder methods you’ve
devised for this terrible creature, but there
were just too many good ones, so we’ll have
to save the rest for another day.
Which means it isn’t too late to tell us
yours!
Let us know your idea down in the comments!
And make sure to subscribe, turn on notifications,
and keep an eye on our community tab so you
can be a part of the next video!
Now check out “SCP-5031 - Yet Another Murder
Monster” and “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” for
more on monsters kept under the Foundation’s
care!